I'm Namie Brooke well Verizon TV and I'm
here at the inside 3d printing
convention and Expo my companies are
showing off some of the latest of
developments in a technology that could
potentially transform the economy so
what exactly is 3d printing 3d printing
is a process that builds up
three-dimensional objects physical
objects by stacking material layer by
layer governed by a design file so not
just printing a picture of a cup of
coffee but actually printing the coffee
cup itself something you can drink out
it prices are coming down which means
that technology is becoming accessible
the consumer scale industry is getting
more involved but big companies are
beginning to use it to make real
products and that means a lot of things
are gonna change you may not have to go
to Sears to buy your screwdriver at some
point you may be able to print the
plastic and the metal parts you need to
make a tool and we'll see parts on
demand where for example a large
manufacturer of dishwashers puts all
their parts online as digital files and
people anywhere they are in the world
who have a 3d printer can print their
own parts in terms of toy manufacturing
for example instead of having 10
varieties of a character that they could
sell at Walmart if the child could scan
their own face and put it onto one of
the products printed out at home they
can take models that are created by say
a company like Mattel and alter them and
then print their own version of it and
actually upload it again to their site
so that other people across the globe to
share and iterations they call them of a
product so it's a constantly organic
moving creation process
one of our customers is called the open
hand project and they're based out of
the UK and they've created a prosthetic
hand that's totally open source and the
proprietary or closed version that
they're mimicking cost about a hundred
thousand dollars
the open hand projects version cost
about $1,000 in terms of build materials
cost of materials so it's two orders of
magnitude less one of the other
interesting applications that we've seen
is in university research labs so at
Michigan Tech they're using 3d printers
to create lab equipment at a fraction of
the cost so one example was a $2,000
meter that a manufacturer was going to
sell the lab instead their campus 3d
printing lab made one for about a
hundred and fifty dollars so this is the
chef jet 3d printer and it's the first
kitchen ready 3d printer so right now
it's printing in a chocolate recipe but
it's compatible with a lot of different
confectionery recipes so you can 3d
print everything from little candies
like you see here to large intricate
cake toppers and everything in between
what can these machines do that a pastry
chef can't do so pastry chefs are true
innovators and artists in their own
right and what we're hoping is that this
is just another tool in their toolbox so
it can make incredibly complex
dimensional structural shapes that maybe
couldn't be made by hand it can also
make things like you see these
interlocking loosely interlocking shapes
but you really couldn't make any other
way but to 3d apprentice you can also do
super customized things like if you're a
bride and you have lace in your wedding
dress you could bring that in and we
could create a cake a cake topper for
your wedding cake that's made kind of in
the form of that lace or an edible
wedding dress or that either one yeah so
super customized well that's one of the
powers of the technology and do you
foresee this machine being available on
the consumer market absolutely so the
chef jet and the chef jet Pro which is
the full color version will be both
available in the second
this year yeah now your company actually
created the world's first 3d printed
metal gun tell me a little bit about
that product and why you decided to do
that we actually had some engineers that
wanted to prove out the technology and
just show in a very dramatic way that it
was usable on a commercial industrial
kind of scale and the gun that we made
is in 1911 browning model gun so it's a
very old gun but we're using two new
technology to produce it or we did on
this one gun and you know that holds
20,000 psi in the chamber every time
it's fired and it's been fired four
thousand times so very good proof of the
technology just to show that it will
work in other applications do you
ultimately see people as being able to
make guns themselves on a home freely
printer well they have they've done
plastic guns but you know they're
dangerous to hold and they're dangerous
to fire and it's not a gun I would want
to fire over the long-term of course
this technology is going to get more and
more sophisticated and the chances of
that happening become greater do you
think that ultimately it's going to be
difficult for government to stop people
creating whatever they want in their
homes oh yeah certainly would be
difficult you know I just don't know
where to go with that one it's not a
thing I've put a lot of thought into we
control our environments and we can
control what we're doing so the home
printer market then you know that's a
whole different story so it's gonna
shake out over time
as a libertarian and a former raisin
staffer what excites you most about this
technology well the fact that the open
source developments have been coming in
over the last five to eight years that's
really what's revitalizing 3d printing
and why it's getting into the hands of
everyone we've seen that as some of the
patents have expired the cost of some of
this technology has gone down by 98%
you're also seeing development and new
ideas come out of high schools even home
inventors a lot of the parts on our
machine were invented by our customers a
lot of times they're just lying around
at home on the weekends and they're
coming up with parts that are better
than what we came up with so I think
it's going to have really interesting
effects on both sides in terms of really
complex versus really simple
developments and I think overall you're
going to see it's going to get more
competitive and prices are keep falling
and so we'll see what happens next
do you see any particular threats to the
3d printing industry such as patent
holders or certain companies who might
want to protect their product
I think the old-school way of thinking
for a patent enforcement it's going to
have to adapt to the new reality because
it's something it's much like the the
music industry
the first few years of the technology
coming out there's going to be a lot of
China fighting the reality this is going
to prove to be unstoppable in terms of
its implementation so I think the whole
intellectual property industry will have
to adapt their models to take into
account that it's going to happen sort
of like being in the 70s and computers
certain things are going to be disrupted
but you have a feeling that a lot of
other things that will be disrupted but
nobody knows what they are very exciting
times because the price is so affordable
now when the artists get a hold of this
technology they'll come up with projects
that we've never even thought about that
will just make the whole space explode